hello and welcome to MongoDB quick start
with Python MongoDB is one of the most
popular and exciting database
technologies around Python there's one
of the most popular and fastest-growing
language there is and these two
technologies work great together and
that's exactly what this course is about
so we're going to quickly get started
with MongoDB write some code against it
and build some realistic applications so
the goal with this class is to teach you
MongoDB we assume you know a little bit
of Python but you'll of course pick some
things up along the way if you don't
know it already and really we want to
get you going quick hence the name
QuickStart so let's get started by
talking about what we're going to cover
in this course we're gonna focus on
three main things we're gonna start with
why do you care about no sequel and
document databases how do document
databases make working with schemas
easier modeling data easier as well as
add performance and flexibility to our
applications we're gonna talk about
modeling specifically because this is
one of the things that is pretty
challenging about document databases if
you come from a relational database
world you probably know about third
normal form this is a way to carefully
in for a structured way to plan out how
you model your data in document
databases you don't really have that
there's a lot more sort of flexibility
in how you design things this is great
for you once you understand it and
you're really good at it but it's
challenging to know how to model things
when you get started because there's so
much flexibility and it's kind of
open-ended
it feels a little more like art that's
in science and in some sense so we're
gonna focus specifically on techniques
and trade-offs and some guidelines i've
come up with to help you be successful
modeling your data with document
databases such as MongoDB and then we're
gonna start writing code for real we're
gonna use a [ __ ] odium object document
mapper think of like sequel alchemy but
for document databases called [ __ ]
engine and we're gonna use that to
create some classes to model or data and
map those classes to and from MongoDB
and use that as the foundation of our
application speaking of applications
what are we gonna build in this class
well we're gonna build an air B&B clone
but for snakes okay so we're gonna build
snake B&B and this allows you and your
traveling with your
take your pet snake you don't want it to
have to live out in the car or something
like that you want to get it as a cage
that it can live in a proper snake cage
no it'll be happy
so there'll be owners of cages who can
put their cages up for rent and snake
owners pet owners who want to travel
with their pets and have their pet have
a place to stay so we're gonna create
this sort of silly Airbnb knockoff clone
but we're gonna model many of the
operations you would see in real Airbnb
on our application here so it's gonna be
pretty rich in terms of data as far as
tools go well of course we're gonna talk
about MongoDB right that's the database
we're using but you're also going to
learn some other things that are pretty
awesome in the course we're gonna talk
about [ __ ] engine this is the primary
library we're gonna use to talk to
MongoDB it's built upon another one
that's a very popular that is sort of
the lowest level official way to talk to
MongoDB called PI [ __ ] so you might see
a little bit of both of those actually
in the course we're gonna use what I
think is the best tool for accessing
[ __ ] DB something used to be called
Robo [ __ ] but now it's called Robo 3t
because it was acquired by a company
called 3t so this is part command line
part GUI way to interact with [ __ ] DB
and it's beautiful and free open-source
it's great also we're gonna use pycharm
for our Python code you don't have these
Python for this course but you'll see me
using it and I think you'll see a lot of
benefits as we go
speaking of me who am i anyway who is
this voice that you're listening to hi
my name is Michael Kennedy you can find
me on Twitter at at M Kennedy and what
makes me qualified to teach this course
well first of all I host the most
popular Python podcast called talk
Python to me and I've interviewed many
many people including some of the folks
from MongoDB the company as well as
authors who have written about MongoDB
design patterns and things like that so
I've had a lot of experience working
with people in Python and MongoDB I've
created the talk Python training company
and written mini Python courses and
MongoDB courses there as well and also
I'm part of the MongoDB master's program
so this is a group of about 35 external
community members who give advice back
to MongoDB and I've been part of this
for many years work closely with the
folks inside MongoDB over the years so
this is what you have in store for you
lots of Awesome mommy-to-be and Python I
hope you're excited let's get right to
it let's begin by looking at why you
might choose MongoDB over other note
sequel databases other document
databases or even other relational
databases I'm sure you've heard him on
TV that's why you're taking this course
but how popular is it relative to other
databases is it really the right choice
well let's look at some data from 2017
if you compare MongoDB against other no
sequel databases cassandra couchdb raven
DB things like that you will find one of
these databases is unlike the others
look at that that's incredible how much
more popular MongoDB is over these and
it's not just the popularity that it's
5-10 times maybe 50 times more popular
than Raven DB that's great it's very
important but also the trend all right
these others are either flat or trending
downwards and this is besides a little
blip here based on probably like the end
of the year numbers or something like
that at the end of the data this is a
really big deal right this is incredible
how much growth that is here and it's
still going up so MongoDB is really
really popular in terms of a database
that people are using and that's great
because that means it's well tested when
we get to section little bit later we'll
look at some of the users
of MongoDB but it's really important
that there are some heavy workloads put
onto these databases you're going to
depend upon and if they can take what
those people are doing surely it can
take what you have to throw at it as
well
now MongoDB is also loved if you look at
Stack Overflow at their 2017 developer
survey and you look at the most loved
databases these are databases that the
developers are using currently and how
they feel about it
you see MongoDB ranks right near the top
so definitely 55% of people who are
using MongoDB love it compared to say
like sequel Lite or Cassandra so this is
pretty good but what's even more
interesting is that it's the most-wanted
database so these are technologies that
you're not currently able to work with
but you would like to so there are tons
of people that want to work with MongoDB
but for whatever reason they've got some
legacy system built on you know my
sequel or whatever they don't get the
chance to so all these pieces of data
tell you MongoDB is a really good
technology to have in your tool belt and
it's easy to get a hold of write MongoDB
is open source and it's free you can
just go to github.com slash MongoDB
slash [ __ ] and clone it and it's right
there
so you can see it has 11,000 stars 3,000
Forks and the screenshot I took here it
was updated two hours ago it's under
very very active development so it's a
live and vibrant project finally if you
actually want to get MongoDB don't go to
github github it's cool it's great the
of the source but don't go there what
you really want to do is you want to go
to MongoDB coms slash download - Center
or just go to mommy D be calm and click
download it'll take you here and you
download it here you get it as binary so
if you're on Mac I recommend you use
homebrew to install it but you can also
download a tarball
if you're on Windows get the MSI and on
Linux you can actually install it with
aptitude or some package manager like
that in this course we're not going to
go in the details of setting up MongoDB
just follow the instructions in the full
MongoDB course you have we walk through
all the steps but we just want to get
started this is the QuickStart so let's
keep moving let's look at one of these
records it's stored in MongoDB to see
how document databases work here we have
a JSON record this is actually from one
of my courses the Python jump start by
building 10 apps and this is how I
represented in the database
we've got stand
third column or type things so we have
an ID we have a title of course ID
duration in seconds these types of
things now first of all you might be
wondering wait a minute JSON database
JSON database is that really efficient
well probably not what MongoDB actually
stores is a binary representation so
like a binary tokenized version of this
record but they call it beasts on
because it's like binary JSON but we're
humans we don't read binary we read text
so we're looking at the textual
representation so there's not exactly
how it gets stored but it's pretty close
so we have these regular column type
pieces of information ID and title and
so on we also have this other thing
these lectures now these lectures are in
this chapter we've represented by this
record from this course and notice the
bracket in JavaScript which basically
this is means that is a array and the
array contains a bunch of sub objects so
this is really interesting instead of
just having a chapter table and a
lecture table and doing a join or
something like that a foreign key
relationship we're actually putting the
lectures inside the same record so this
is pretty interesting when you look at
it like this you can imagine that this
is like a pre computer join if I do a
query for the lecture say given ID 1001
and I get this record back it already
has the lectures I don't have to make
another round-trip to the database to
get them I don't have to do a join
against several tables in that original
query it's literally a primary key query
against an indexed primary key and is
insanely fast and yet it already comes
back with all this extra information so
this is really cool if I gets a chapter
I have two lectures great but you might
be wondering well really what if I need
to ask the question in Reverse like
fundamentally if I need to get at
lecture 10,000 106 will I be able to
query MongoDB quickly and efficiently
to get that lecture and it turns out the
answer is yes and that's why document
databases are awesome it's not just like
some nested blobs stored in the original
record you can as part of the query
language and part of indexes perverse
these hierarchies and very very rich and
powerful ways so we don't lose very much
query capability just by putting their
lectures in this one
record so this is really neat and this
is sort of the foundational most
important takeaway from document
databases we store them as these
flexible JSON type of objects and we can
nest additional things like lists of
numbers or even sub documents as we have
in this case
now before we move on let's take a
moment and look at who uses MongoDB now
programming languages and databases and
technologies aren't necessarily
popularity contests just because
something's popular it doesn't
necessarily mean that it's great you
know evidence PHP for example or VB or
something like this technologies are
popular and some of them are great and
sometimes great technologies are popular
so there are some important things that
come along with being popular and used
in by big important companies and that
means these things are durable and
tested and they've really been through
the wringer so MongoDB has been used by
some really big customers and some
really interesting use cases and I know
some of the biggest ones are actually
not on this page even they're not listed
here so I'm gonna take in a quick tour
of a couple of customers who are using
MongoDB and we'll look at how they're
using it ok so the first one that I want
to look at how let's scroll down here
you see some names that you might know
some cool stuff here let's check out
Royal Bank of Scotland so banks are
supposed to be conservative right things
like this that probably wouldn't use
weird no sequel document databases are
gonna stick to their traditional Oracle
or sequel server or whatever well if we
look at Royal Bank of Scotland they're
using Mahara DB to support a global
enterprise data service underpinning
several core trading systems if your
bank the core trading system is pretty
much the center center of the universe
right so the fact that they're driving
that with [ __ ] and that's high
performance and it's doing that for them
that's really awesome
let's check out Expedia so Expedia they
have their app built on MongoDB and
they're supporting millions of customers
shopping for flights hotels cars things
like that that's pretty awesome let's
check out another one down here EA so
video games all right this is the
world's best-selling sports game
franchise and they rely on MongoDB to
scale the millions of players that it's
really awesome one more before we move
on so these guys down here a little
farther at sail through sail through is
a company that does like outbound mail
and analytics and things like that so
they are a marketing company very much
doing tons of email type of stuff like I
said and they have over 40 terabytes of
data in a hundred and twenty physical
mostly physical nodes all right so a
hundred and twenty servers all working
running MongoDB and some giant cluster
which is a pretty awesome use case and
of course you have things like
Shutterfly running a MongoDB Squarespace
on and on there's a ton of cool use
cases down here but I think you've got
the idea
are you ready to model some real
applications in MongoDB using documents
it's time to get our hands dirty and
really start building something so in
this chapter we're gonna go through our
snake B&B application come up with the
entities the classes and tables or
collections as they're called in MongoDB
and model them out so we're gonna first
look at how this modeling and document
databases compares to traditional third
normal form modeling in relational
databases we use a pretty simple example
but I think you'll get the idea and
you'll see it much more in action when
we build the real app so let's take this
simple book store model here we have
books they have a bunch of properties we
have people who publish those books
named publishers they have a name when
they were founded and you can navigate
this foreign key relationship from
publisher over to the publisher ID on
the book now we also have a user and a
user might rate a book so we have users
and we have ratings and we have a
foreign key relationship between them
and they know from rating over to book
we have a one-to-many relationship there
right a book can have many ratings so we
have a couple of foreign key
relationships going on in this place now
let me tell you in a real application
there'd be many more little tables with
extra information like this like ratings
about books and so on and let's say
reviews for example things like that
maybe even related items that we pre
computed from some sort of machine
learning but we want to store that in
the database so imagine this model here
having like 15 tables with relationships
across all the various pieces back and
forth right so I just want to keep it
simple fits on the screen you're not
gonna go crazy with it so how would we
model this in MongoDB
how will we model this using documents
well you would see that it's somewhat
simpler the more craziness that we had
on a relational model the sort of more
contrast you will see here so we still
have our publisher and they have their
ID and when they were founded we have
our user and the same columns or pieces
of information there as well Seamans
book but now our ratings we've decided
you know when we get a book most of the
time we actually want to know the rating
we
I say like this is a 3.4 star book or it
has 72 ratings even in a list we want to
show that stuff so we're pretty sure we
want to have these ratings always with
the books so why put them in a separate
table let's embed them now we still have
some relationships like we had in the
relational model for example we have our
publisher ID on books and that links
over to publisher now this is what in
MongoDB I refer to as a soft foreign key
constraint if there's a relationship
between books and publisher it's the
publisher ID set to the idea of the
publisher but the database itself
doesn't enforce this right so you need
to be a little more careful in your app
and we'll see how we do that when we get
to the code but as I was saying about
ratings these were not gonna put in a
separate collection in fact we're gonna
store those inside of our books so we
can embed these objects and arrays of
either straight values like numbers or
strings or actual sub documents like our
ratings here so whenever a 1 2 3 and so
on it's actually part of the record of
the book so we're gonna get the book
record back we already have the ratings
things like that so again we can think
of this radians being embedded within
books as a precomputed join there's a
slight bit of overhead if you actually
wanted the book without the ratings and
you're just gonna get him back and
ignore them most of the time anyway if
that was the case but if most of the
time you do want the radians this is a
huge speed-up and like I said imagine
there were 15 tables before and 5 of
them could be collapsed into the books
you have a five-way join going down to a
single primary key query that'd be
amazing
as we discussed modeling with documents
and document databases is a little bit
more art there's a little bit more
flexibility and kind of just gut feel of
how you should do it but let me give you
some guidelines that will give you a
clear set of considerations as you work
on your data models you'll see that the
primary question for working with
document databases is to embed or not to
embed that is when there's a
relationship between two things in your
application should one of those be a sub
document should be contained within the
same record as the thing it is related
to or should they be to separate
collections what MongoDB calls tables
collections because they're not tabular
right should those be two separate
collections that just relate to each
other so we're going to try to answer
this
I'll try to provide you some guidelines
for answering this question so the first
one is is the embedded data wanted 80%
of the time when you have the the outer
or other related object okay so let's go
back to our example we just worked with
we had a book in the book had radians so
to make this concrete the question here
is do we care about having information
about the ratings most of the time when
we're working with books
so if our website like lists books and
that that listing has the number of
radians and the average Radian and
things like that listed as part of the
listing you pull up a book maybe the
ratings and the reviews are shown right
there most of the time layout of the
book we have radians involved somehow
then we would want to embed the radians
within the book right that's what we did
in our data model and we said yes
actually we do want the ratings most of
the time now let's look at this in
Reverse how often do you want the
embedded data without the containing
document so in the same example how
often is it the case that you would like
the ratings without the book
so what use case is for maybe like where
would that show up in our app so like
maybe you as a user go to your profile
page and the book store and there you
can see all the books you've rated right
and the the details about the rain you
don't actually care about necessarily
the books you just want these are the
ratings that I've given two things and
here's my comments and so on I don't
actually want most of the details or
maybe any of the details about the book
itself so if you're in that sort of
situation a lot of the time you might
want to put that into a separate
collection and not embed it you can
still do it you can still do this query
and it'll come back very quickly there's
ways to work with it but you'll see that
you have to do a query against the
database and then a little bit of
filtering on the application side so
it's not prohibitive it's not that you
can't get the containing document with
the contained document without it's a
container but it's a little bit more
clumsy alright so if this is something
you frequently want to do then maybe
consider not embedding it now is the
embedded document a bounded set so let's
look at radians how many radians might a
book have ten readings a hundred radians
a thousand radians is that number gonna
just grow grow the number of radians
that we have if this was like pageviews
and details about the browser or an IP
address and date and time of a page be
viewed
not make a good candidate for embedding
that like say for views of a book
because that could just grow and grow
and grow as the popular your site grows
and it could make the document so large
that we can retrieve it from the
database actually the network traffic
and the disk traffic would be a problem
I don't really see that happening with
ratings I mean even on Amazon like super
popular books have hundreds not millions
of Radiance so it is probably okay but
if it's an unbounded set you do not want
to embed it and is that bound small
right like maybe millions of views still
being recorded within sign of a book
would be a really bad idea and the
reason is these documents are limited to
16 megabytes so no single record in
MongoDB can be larger than 16 megabytes
and this is not a limitation of MongoDB
this is them trying to protect you from
yourself you do not want to go and just
say query by say ISBN and try to pull
back a book and actually read a hundred
megabytes off a disk and over the
network that would destroy the
performance to your database so having
these very very large records it's a
problem so they actually set an upper
bound on how large that can be and that
limit is right now currently at the time
of the recording 16 megabytes but you
shouldn't think of 16 megabytes as like
well if it's 10 megabytes everything's
fine we're still got a long ways to go
now you should try to keep these you
know in the kilobytes tens 20 hundreds
of kilobytes not megabytes because
that's gonna really hurt your database
performance unless it some situation it
just makes a ton of sense to have these
very large documents so having small
bounded sets means that your documents
won't grow and a huge huge monolithic
things that are hard to work with also
how varied are your queries so one of
the things that you do with document
databases is you try to structure the
documents to answer the most common
questions in the most well structured
way all right so if you're always going
to say I would like to on my pages show
a book and it's related ratings you
would absolutely put the ratings inside
the book because that means you just do
a query against a book and you already
have that like kind of pre joined data
but if it's sort of a data warehouse and
you're asking all kinds of questions
from all different sorts of applications
then try and understand well what is the
right way to build my document so it
matches the queries I typically do or
the ones that I need to be really quick
and fast
that becomes hard because there's all
these different queries and they have
like you know one the way you model for
one is actually the opposite of the way
you model for the other
alright so depending how focused your
application is or how many applications
are using the database you'll have a
different answer this question so the
more specific your queries are the more
likely or to embed things and structure
them exactly to match those queries
related to that is are you working with
an integration database or an
application database we'll get to that
next so wait what is an integration
database so if you were just working on
your own personal website or some small
project you don't have an integration
database but if you work at a big
enterprise a big corporation where
there's many internal systems you may be
working with an integration database and
honestly that's not a great fit for no
sequel databases in general but it also
makes designing documents for them more
difficult so in large corporations we
have many applications that share the
same data one way that we have built
applications to share data is to just
share the same database so we might have
a bunch of different applications and
they're all going to talk to the same
database so they all have the same
concept of a user they all have the same
concept of an order things like that and
this means the concept of the user is as
complicated as it can get maybe the
application the top left could have a
real simple user the one on the top
right actually needs something else
the bottom one is something else still
and so you've kind of got a model across
all these applications and that makes it
super tricky also in new sequel
databases and document databases the
relationships are enforced in the
application so that means the all of
these have to agree on what the
constraints are what the relationships
are and that can actually cause data
integrity issues so there's a lot of
reasons that integration database isn't
a great idea for relational databases in
fact it's not a great idea at all but it
has been used and because there's
different applications with different
query patterns it makes designing your
documents more difficult so instead what
do we do we build application databases
maybe we have a bunch of different
applications just like before but they
all have their own data store and they
all talk to their own databases of
course they need to exchange data like
before so maybe we do some sort of micro
service thing where they talk to a
service boss or they just talk to each
other things like that and that means
each individual dream database and
interaction
it's own application is super super
focused and limited and here in these
cases MongoDB
document databases make a lot more sense
and it's easier to design the documents
because the range of queries is
extremely focused so you can target
those particular questions against a
small set of queries the guidelines we
just talked about so you this is the
kind of model you want to have if you're
doing data exchange within your
organization and you're working with a
document database I don't know about you
but I feel like we've talked about
coding and talked about MongoDB in
theory enough and it's time to write
some code and use MongoDB so that brings
us to getting started with our demo
application so throughout the rest of
the course we're gonna spend a
significant amount of time focusing on
this and remember we're building snake
B&B this wonderful experience were snake
owners and their pets can share other
snake cages when they're traveling so
they feel totally comfortable on every
vacation you need to take your snake on
course is just a knockoff of Airbnb type
thing and in this video we're gonna see
how to get it from github and how to get
it up and running in Python and PyCharm
so we'll start out over here on
github.com slash mic see Kennedy slash
MongoDB - QuickStart - course and you
can see that we've got a couple of
things here we've got some data this is
empty right now but I'm gonna fill it up
with stuff as we go through the class
you'll be able to recreate the database
so the instructions in there and how to
restore that and then if you go over to
source this is the most interesting part
we're gonna be working in this area here
but I've made a snapshot of starter code
snake BB and this is exactly a snapshot
of what we're starting from okay but I'm
gonna be working in here because I want
to have it build up right also try to do
make some ranches or other save points
really obvious when we get to the
various videos right now there's no
other branches but we'll get to those ok
let's go and check this out so we'll go
copy what we need and we'll say get
clone this nice and quick and let's go
work with it so over here
we have our source code and we have our
snake BB and we have our starter code
snake b and b so these are the the two
projects here and what I want to do is
I'm gonna put this in the pie chart on
Mac OS you can just drag and drop this
on a pie chart and load the project from
that folder however if you do this on
Windows or on Linux I think you have to
go to pycharm it's a file open directory
however before I do let's go into this
folder really quick and create a virtual
environment so you may be familiar pod
on and virtual environments and so on
but if you're not let me give you the
quick overview of what's and what's
going on here if we look here we're
gonna have apparently a misspelled
requirements file which we're going to
take care of in a second but notice in
this requirements file these are the
external libraries PI [ __ ] and [ __ ]
engine for MongoDB and some other random
stuff for working with color output on
the console as well as parsing date
times entered from the user so we need
these libraries and we don't want to
install them and manage them basically
as a machine wide thing we would install
them into our virtual environment so
let's go over here in first your name
requirements and we're gonna go and
actually create the virtual environment
and then we'll install we can install
stuff into it so here we are again and
the source folder so we'll say Python 3
- M V and V so run the virtual
environment module into dot env this
naming convention dot MV something that
pine term understands will automatically
detect and start using we're gonna past
- copies flag it's only required on Mac
OS I believe but anyway we'll go with
that
now if we do an LS eh you can see this
hidden DMV but we don't need to do
anything else with it pycharm should
take it from here so we can go and grab
this folder on Mac OS remember equal
file open directory on the other OSS and
drop it here so let's go ahead and tell
PyCharm about get the very first time
PyCharm won't index the Python
environment we gave it and then it
should be up and running okay so let's
look down here in the terminal you
should see the dot E and V you can ask
questions like which Python and it
showed you it's the one that we created
in Windows that's where Python not which
Python if we go over here we have our
requirements and so on now the other
thing we need to do is we need to
right-click
and say set this as like the relative
path so in this file when I import some
other file it looks relative to that so
you can say right click here and say
mark directory as sources root or just
be in this folder when you run it in
Python and basically your working
directory okay so we're almost ready to
run things the last thing we need to do
is install these requirements so we can
say pip install - are the requirements
file and that will install those
libraries for us so when we run the
application it has everything it needs
so if we try to run it now it'll crash
and say it can't find Kelly Robyn or
something like that
now this application is empty it doesn't
do anything other than ask for a couple
of prompts there's no data access for
MongoDB anything
in here but let's go ahead and just get
it to run so we can right click on
program and right click and say run
program it runs and you can see if I
make it bigger here we have our snake
B&B and I put a little snake there for
you guys and it asks you a question or
you a guest or a host are you looking
for a cage or do you want to offer up
your cage so let's go with guest and it
lets you do things like create an
account had your snake so on so I could
say I'd like to login so do you know
that's not implemented yet in fact
that's what we're gonna be doing next is
implementing all of these features in
the database creating an account logging
in poking a cage viewing cages things
like that right so all the actions you
might do in a typical Airbnb situation
so that's it for now we have this up and
running let's do one more thing because
of the output this I find this looks a
little better if we just run it separate
outside of pycharm so we can say copy
the path here and we're still in this
folder with the dot environment so we
need to activate it if we're gonna run
it over here so we would say a dot space
thought Ian v's has been in a slash
activate on Windows you don't need the
first thought and it's not been its
script script or scripts I can't
remember I think it's scripts either way
a prompt to change
and now we can run this here's our snake
again okay so we're all set up and ready
to run our code it's time to write some
code against MongoDB and connect to
MongoDB and we're gonna do that with an
odium and object document mapper this
terms new to you think of object
relational mapper like sequel alchemy
but for document databases instead so
let's compare first this odm style of
programming against the most basic
lowest level way to program or interact
with MongoDB from Python called PI [ __ ]
so every programming language that you
can talk to MongoDB from there's many of
them 20 30 I don't know something like
that many many languages can talk to
MongoDB and they each have what's called
a driver and this is typically provided
by MongoDB the company itself so PI
[ __ ] is no different it's this
low-level foundational way to talk to
MongoDB and you do this in the native
query syntax of MongoDB this JavaScript
JSON style of interacting with the
database now it's important to know that
if you're working with MongoDB in terms
of running and managing it but from
writing code we're gonna focus on
something higher level and odium so we
can take structured classes and map
those to and from the database so let's
see how it would work if we just use PI
Monga so we've got our app here and we
have the PI [ __ ] package we're gonna
work with and we have MongoDB the
database so we write direct queries in
this raw MongoDB API so you have to know
the API really carefully you have to map
those back to your classes basically
what you do is you pass dictionaries to
PI [ __ ] it uses those as part of the
query and then you get the dictionaries
back pretty unstructured but it's very
low-level and fast with an odium
similarly we've got our app and we've
got PI [ __ ] and MongoDB but we also
have another layer the layer that we
directly interact with called the odium
object document mapper and there's a
bunch of different kinds there's [ __ ]
engine there's Ming there's [ __ ] kit
there's [ __ ] alchemy mini [ __ ] and
there's a more than that actually
there's a ton of them just so happens
we're gonna use [ __ ] engine one of the
more popular and well-polished ones I
think so in this model we don't query in
terms of raw dictionaries against PI
[ __ ] we just talked to the classes
defined by the Oh DM and
queries are based on those types on
those classes that itself will translate
to the MongoDB API sometimes in real
basic ways sometimes really advanced
ways and it will actually leverage some
of the advanced operators the dollar
operators if you're familiar with them
for long would you be like dollar set
dollar add to set things like this so
really really cool that it leverages the
advanced operators not just you know
save this document read this document
type of programming
I think the odium model is a much better
way to write your application you'll see
there's not much structure in a schema
list database so having a little bit of
extra structure defined by these classes
that are part of this odm model really
adds a lot of safety to your application
in my opinion the odium we're gonna use
for this course is [ __ ] engine and you
can find its home page and details about
it documentation and so on that [ __ ]
engine org so Mago engine is open-source
like many things you'll find in Python
as we said it depends upon PI [ __ ] you
saw us install it earlier we just did
pip install [ __ ] engine and that
installed PI [ __ ] along with it we did
that through the requirements file but
you can do that directly if you prefer
you can find [ __ ] engine on github you
can see that it's quite popular almost
2,000 stars this is much more popular
than the other MongoDB ODMs
as far as I can tell look into other
ones this is definitely the most popular
or at least among the most popular of
them and it's very actively under
development I just took the screenshot
right now before I started recording
here to give you the latest version you
can see that it's been updated in the
last 24 hours some other stuff under the
actual code has been updated in the last
21 hours so very active this is
important for an open source project
you're going to depend upon so I think
you know judging by that [ __ ] engine is
the best choice and the API is excellent
we're gonna start working with it next
the first thing we need to do to start
working with [ __ ] engine is tell [ __ ]
engine how to speak to MongoDB let's go
back to our snake being the app we've
been working on and we're going to go in
here to this data section and we're
gonna create a new file a Python file
called [ __ ] setup so in here we're
going to write a simple method that we
can call from other places in as you'll
see in the slides that we look at later
for real
locations that use proper connections
encryption accounts things like that
this could be a little more complicated
but it's going to start out pretty
simple so we'll say global in it and in
here we just want to call one function
so we're gonna have to have [ __ ] engine
here so we'll import [ __ ] engine and we
just say [ __ ] engine dot register
connection and the first thing that we
pass is an alias so I'll be real
explicit say alias equals core now what
is this alias thing about we can have
multiple connections to even multiple
databases or even multiple database
servers registered here so we could have
like a core data and say analytics for
just analytics it goes to a separate
database that maybe has tons more data
because it's like page views and actions
and so on but we might keep that
separate so we can back it up on a
separate schedule something like that
and then we need to set the name of the
database and we'll set that to snake B&B
do a quick format here and it's all good
to go
like I said this gets more interesting
in real connections but we're going to
need to call this to talk to mama DB so
let's go over to our little program and
you saw up here at the top there was
this to do set up [ __ ] engine global
values and that was basically what we
were doing there so we need to come over
here and say you need to go to data dot
[ __ ] to set up as what's called [ __ ]
setup and this should be pretty simple
[ __ ] set up dot global in it we know we
just need to make sure we call this once
in our application and we need to do
this before we actually interact with
anything else so let's go and apply
these settings over to our entities as
well so we'll look at snakes first now
this model is going to be mapped into
one or more of those databases well one
among many potential databases so the
way that we can tell it how to work
[ __ ] engine we'll use a property we can
add to it we can say meta equals and we
give it a dictionary and we can say DB
underscore alias and we'll say cor here
okay while we're at it let's say
collection is snakes so even though we
called it capital s snake the thing in
the database were these records these
documents are stored what we called
snakes plural lowercase and here we can
tell if this goes into the core database
unlike maybe the analytics one or
something like right we're only going to
have one in here but for our example you
want to
have this year so in case you want to
add more later right I'll go ahead and
add the rest of these two owners and
cages but not bookings because bookings
is going to be nested inside here all
right so we don't need to tell that how
it gets stored because it's stored
alongside cage cages and no surprise
owners all right so those are our three
top level entities that map to our three
top-level collections in MongoDB now
we've registered the connection by using
our [ __ ] setup global which we just
call register connection like I said
this couldn't get way more complicated
in reality and then we just go and we
set this meta to use the core connection
as well as naming the actual table
collection it's going to go to let's
take a moment and look at this concept
of registering connections we're going
to need to work with Moggridge and so of
course import [ __ ] engine and we need
to set the alias and the name of the
database so it's a [ __ ] agent not
registered connection give it the alias
give it the name we need to call this
for we start interacting with our
classes and other types before we try it
a few any queries or save any data this
has to be all set up so this is what we
wrote in our application and this works
fine when you're talking to the local
MongoDB running no encryption no
accounts default port running on the
local machine same machine as this code
how if you're doing this in production
there's more to it
all right you need to set the username
and password which you have to set up in
MongoDB there's none by default so you
got to set that up with the right
permissions probably it's a different
server on a alternative port so set the
host and the port you would like to
create of some sort of admin account
which is associated with that username
and password so you say look you
authenticate and admin use this
mechanism and finally if you're gonna do
connections across you know so we're
outside your data set and you pretty
much should just turn this on is you
need to turn on SSL and configure the
server for SSL and then you pass that
additional data in addition to the alias
and the DB now there's a lot going on
here and deployment and running MongoDB
and production is not as simple maybe as
it could be certainly it's something you
need to be very careful about like no
authentication no encryption right don't
run your code that way it's fine to do
it for development but don't do it for
word production in my full MongoDB
course I actually go in to spend an hour
go and create a Linux server and set it
up in a cluster of
database and the web servers and those
kinds of things and really make this
work perfectly and safely but in this
course we're not going to go into it I
just want to leave you with you need to
set it us up you can look at the MongoDB
org site as well MongoDB comm site and
go through the documentation on some of
the steps or just take my other course
if you're really going to go and use
this in production
so far we've modeled in our data with
Python classes but there was no real
[ __ ] engine entity stuff they wouldn't
actually be saved or processed by [ __ ]
engine just happens to be we kind of
sketched them out in Python class style
so we're gonna change that now we're
gonna go make our standard plain old
Python classes proper [ __ ] engine
entities snake is pretty simple so let's
start there
so in order to work with [ __ ] engine
over here I'm gonna have to import it
now you might want to do from [ __ ]
engine import some things but I like to
be real explicit like these things are
coming from [ __ ] engine even in my
production code so this is how I'm gonna
do it and we're gonna set the register
date to a particular type of descriptor
that comes from [ __ ] engine and add
sort of the type level this tells [ __ ]
engine what type of data and constraints
and requirements go on to this field
however at run time is going to act like
say a date time or whatever it is in
this case the date time and species
would be string and so on so we'll come
over say [ __ ] engine dot date/time
field and we'll see like this so this
will tell [ __ ] engine to map that to
the database as a date/time field over
here we'll say [ __ ] engine dot string
field and over here the length let's say
this is in meters and that's probably
decent F floats right so this will be a
float field the name again a string
field whether it's venomous or not
that's true or false guess it could be a
number like level of venomous I don't
know but we're gonna call this a boolean
field and that's that so our snake is
all ready to map into MongoDB well good
UB doesn't have things like required
fields or default values or anything
like that but [ __ ] engine does so let's
change this to make it a little simpler
to create a snake so for example
register date is almost always just
whenever you inserted it right so what
we can do is we come over here and set a
default function that will execute
anytime [ __ ] ancient inserts a new
snake so we're gonna start with date
time and so the function that we want to
call is the now function which gives us
a full year month day hour minute second
representation of time so we'll come in
here say date/time dot date/time dot now
and be very careful not to put the
parentheses you're passing the function
not the how you of now that would be
like when the program started so that
can be a little tricky over here for
species let's say that you have to save
the species so we can say this is gonna
be required is true in fact the length
is required the name is required whether
it's venomous is required we could have
in things like minimum values have to be
like 0.01 or you know things like this
all right so you can't have like a
negative length there's a lot of cool
constraints that we can do with our
types here so this snake is now ready to
be used in our database let's look at
the next one let's work on the cage next
so again impor
[ __ ] engine I'll use that in a few
places this is exactly the same here so
set the default and then the name is
gonna be a string and so on
so I'll just sketch these out for you
so these seem like reasonable types here
and let's go ahead and set the required
properties for things that we will
require so most of these will be
required and whether or not we allow
dangerous snakes if you don't set that
let's say no by default you're not going
to have a dangerous snake okay so these
are just like the snake before this
however gets more interesting so we're
gonna come down here and we're gonna set
this to be a [ __ ] engine dot embedded
document so we could have just a single
thing like a booking or like say embed
the snake in the owner or something like
that but we want to have a list of
embedded documents then what we need to
pass in here is the actual type that is
contained in there so we're going to
import data dot bookings booking one
other thing that I also realized I
forgot to do in the previous one so
we'll go back and fix that is we need to
tell [ __ ] engine that this is a
top-level document so we need to make
this have a base plot of type document
we'll do that for snakes as well
now let's go to booking we were just
working with that so this one recall is
it's the type that's embedded within of
the cage vetted in the cage that means
it's not a document I'd be a top-level
thing this is an embedded document
alright so this can be contained within
other documents but it itself cannot be
top-level so let's go ahead and set
these as well
now when we're talking about IDs and
MongoDB the default is something called
an object ID like a UUID or good or
something and so when we're talking
about a reference typically one of these
it doesn't have to be but it typically
is there we go
so we've got our two references as
object IDs we've got our booking date
which does not have to be required and
doesn't have a default value this is
when it was booked which happens after
the booking slot was made available and
but at the time of creation of the slot
of booking right would like put it up
for booking you have to say the check-in
and check-out date and again the reviews
these are not getting set until after I
said this to zero so we can say like you
know require it to be one to five if
they actually rate the thing and then
you can sort of exclude the ones that
are zero if I don't want as owner and
it's very very similar I'll just sketch
that out for you okay so we've got our
flat pieces here are registered a name
and email and now we're going to have a
list of ID's so we'll come in here and
say [ __ ] engine dot list field for both
of them
so this will let us store the object IDs
that refer to the snakes in object IDs
that refer to the cages last thing to do
is make the base class the document here
all right so what have we done we've
said all the fields to their respective
types out of [ __ ] engine as descriptors
we've set either default or required
values and we set the metadata which
talks about which database connection to
use and what to call the collection when
it goes into the database and we've done
that for our three top-level items here
the one that is different that stands
out is the booking which is embedded
within the cage and this is an embedded
document but otherwise everything goes
pretty much the same
let's review the core concepts around
creating [ __ ] engine entities we
started out by cream what I called basic
classes these are our classes that could
just as easily been mapped to a
relational database because they just
have flat fields or columns if you want
to think of them that way and none of
the nested or particular capabilities of
document databases so the one that
matched that was the snake and the snake
we make sure that it derives from [ __ ]
engine document and then we specify the
fields by passing along or creating
these [ __ ] engine descriptors so he
said there's a registered date and
that's a [ __ ] engine date/time field
the length that was a float that was the
length of the snake in meters the name
of the snake is a string species as in a
and as a string as well and whether or
not it's venomous that's a boolean true
or false so you can see we can map out
the types for this basic snake class
really easily here of course our snake
should have default values constraints
like required fields and things like
that so here we've taken the same snake
class and we've added a default value
for the register date we said just call
the function date/time date/time dot now
anytime you insert a new snake so it's
gonna automatically tag that new entity
or that new document with the date in
which it was inserted now remember be
super careful did not call the function
now but passed the function now okay we
also set the length to a float we said
that's a required float you have to
specify the length or it'll your [ __ ]
engine will give you an error so you
can't insert this thing that field is
required it's interesting that that's
not a feature of MongoDB that's a
feature of [ __ ] engine so by using
[ __ ] engine instead of say PI [ __ ] we
get these additional features same for
the default and name species and
venomous also these are all required so
we can do this here now again this is
still one of these sort of basic classes
with just our constraints and defaults
let's look at the cage the cage is more
takes better advantage of the document
database so we have the name the price
the square meters required standard
stuff there we also have the bookings
these are either this times in which a
cage could be booked or an active
booking where a snake
registered to be there on a certain time
when we model that through the booking
class and we said this cage is going to
embed the bookings into it so to do that
we use the [ __ ] engine embedded
document list panel so a list of
embedded documents and the argument we
pass is the type of embedded document so
it's a booking that we're putting into
this list right now how does this look
if we populate this cage and we add a
couple bookings and we call save well it
looks like this has the standard fields
right like a auto-generated underscore
ID the date that was registered this is
set as the default value in the full
class we have the name the price the
square metres and so on so that's all
standard stuff and we've seen that
before
but the bookings part check that out so
we have bookings and it's a list right
square brackets technically an array in
JavaScript right and the items in this
list are those bookings so we have a
check-in date checkout date and the
ratings so we've have added two bookings
in here now we didn't fill out the
they're not booked so we don't have a
guest snake and a owner ID and they
haven't already taken them so they
haven't raided it or given a review so
some of the pieces are not saved into
the database to save space nonetheless
here we have our embedded bookings
inside of our document and we did that
through the embedded document list field
we have our models our classes in place
we have [ __ ] engine registered and told
to connect to the default values for all
the local stuff for MongoDB running
locally I already have MongoDB started
up and running check out the
documentation on how to get that working
on your operating system like I said at
the beginning and it's time to create an
account log in basically start
implementing all these actions and now
we'll really get to start programming
with the entities we've designed in
[ __ ] engine so let's begin by going
down here to create account in program
host and we're going to be able to use
this for actually both the host and the
guests alright so you can see there's a
couple things we have to do and then
we're gonna create the account so let's
to work on this get name and email first
we'll say name equals and we'll just use
some
input stuff what is your name something
like this and we'll do email email we
should of course have them you know give
us a password and things like that but
it's not a real website we're not really
actually logging in it's just sort of a
user of creation and type thing so we're
gonna create the account now I could go
write the [ __ ] engine code to talk to
[ __ ] and do the inserts here but you'll
see that we can do much much better if
we isolate all of these behaviors within
a central location that we can use
throughout our application in these no
sequel databases these document
databases there's not much structure in
the database so we already have some
structure added by having our classes
our [ __ ] engine types that we work with
but we can also do a little bit better
by having like a centralized data access
piece so that's what we're gonna work
with here let's go create something
called a data service and we'll just put
a bunch of functions that we need to
work with here so let's go back and
let's import this and I'm gonna import
it in like a little short way so we'll
say import services not data service as
SVC okay we're just going to use the
functions out of that module by calling
it that so if we come back down here so
to say not implemented want to say this
so SVC dot create an account and we're
going to pass the name and the email
what we're going to get back is an
account so we want to actually store
that in in the statefulness of our
application again in a web app this
would be with cookies and we get it back
from the database every time but we have
this state thing which has an active
account so what we're gonna do is we're
going to come over here and we're gonna
say state dot active account equals this
so we're gonna get back an account from
here now pycharm says well there's
something going on here there's no
account there's no method called create
account on a function but if I hit alt
enter then it'll say you want to create
one course we want to create one surname
let's even give this a little bit of
typing type in here say it's gonna
return an owner okay so that's all well
and good now we need to use this so now
we get to programming with [ __ ] engine
how do we create one of these owners
well how would you do it if it was a
regular class you would say this and you
would set some properties like name
equals name owner
email is that and now we want to put it
in the database so we do that by calling
using what's called the active record
designed better
we'll just call save right on this now
we want to return owner now the
important point here is when we call
save all the default values are set when
we call save the primary key the
underscore ID is automatically generated
here it's just dot ID at [ __ ] engine
but in the database level underscore ID
that's automatically set so this thing
is up and running and we should have
everything working well here so let's go
ahead and try to run this and see if
everything's hanging together let me run
it over this
you
here's our snake B&B we're gonna go and
say we're a host notice at the prompt
here this little yellow thing there's no
name so we'll go and create an account
just with my name my name is Michael and
my email is a Michael at talk Python dot
F M boom Ogden you can see now the
prompt has my logged in name the next
thing we got to do let's just go from
top to bottom let's go and login however
there is a problem what if I say I want
to create an account I say my name is
Michael - I say it's Michael at talk
Python dot M if I hit enter there's just
two of those that's bad so what we want
to do is we want to do a little check
over here
so this is great we got this working and
let's go ahead and annotate the type
here as well let's say this is an owner
that's gonna let us when we interact
with it later say things like this and
get you know all the intellisense and
whatnot snake ids and whatever okay now
before we do this we want to verify that
the count doesn't exist so we'll say
hold account you'll say find an account
by email and again this doesn't exist so
we'll create this function over here
this will let us see how to query all
right so to insert the create one of
these and we call save to do the query
we're gonna do like this will say owner
equals we work with the type and we say
objects now there's a couple of things
we could do it we could say filter kind
of lose autocomplete here but that's
fine we could say filter and we could
say email equals email okay so we would
match one of the fields there alright
and we would not put that of course and
this is going to return a query and we
want just one of them so we'll say first
now it turns out when you have just one
filter statement you can actually
condense it down like this so we'll go
ahead and write that I'll just say
return anotr okay so there's our find
account by email and it will check if
old account it'll be none if it's not
found so if there's an old account we'll
print I've wrote a few functions error
message success message with some
coloration we'll say error account with
email already exists and let's make this
a cool Python 3 6 F string
like so of course we want to bail we
don't want to actually create it here we
could maybe do something like that print
let's do the success
created new account with ID and let's
say state dot active account ID like so
let's just run this up one more time
you
so I come in as a
I'll create an account let's call this
call it Sara
so Sara wants to come in maybe she's
gonna be able to like she's gonna be a
guest but right when he's this host path
to do it for a second there so Sara ad
talk Python Donna femme great we've
created a new account now let's just
test this thing again
so we'll say I want to create an account
again Sara doesn't actually matter let's
say Susie and it's Sara ad talk Python
dot F M this should no longer work it
should go and query the database and
find this and no no no error an account
email Sara talk Python already exists
perfect I think the create account is
done
so we save some data and it looked like
it went into the database right when we
successfully saved it we saw an idea was
generated when we tried to log in with
the same or create an account the same
email we got an error no no that already
exists so it's definitely working but
let's look at the data with my favorite
tool for working with MongoDB ribbo 3d I
used to be called Robo [ __ ] Robo 3t so
here it is and you can see just by
virtue of calling save that actually
connected to the database created this
particular Crick connects to the server
create this database and the various
collections we only called save on
owners so we only have owners so far
never mind the fact that we've created
the other types we haven't saved
anything there so it doesn't exist and
we can come down here and we can save
you documents and we actually have the
two documents here remember we created
two accounts and we can view them this
way and there you go we have Michael and
my email Sarah and her email the
registered dates and times and we know
long we we don't yet have a snake or a
cage because well we haven't implemented
the ability to do that but we're gonna
have snake ID and cage IDs in here as we
create these snakes and cages this is a
really great way to work with the data
if you go back to this mode you can even
edit it and make changes in here if you
really wanted to all right so definitely
recommend installing this it works on
all the platforms it's free and it's
awesome
able to create account so let's now add
the ability to login once we exit the
application so we're over here in the
log into account and the program host
this is super easy
we're just have to get the email from
the user like this so we'll say
something to the fact of Joanna login
ask them what their email is and let's
go ahead and do a strip and they not
lower on this and in fact let's always
store that so I'll go back up to our
create account and do that here so strip
takes all the white space in case
there's like a space or something on the
end and lower of course makes it
lowercase so then we just need to see if
the account exists
well we actually already wrote that so
let's say this so the account is the
service not find account by guess it
email and then we'll say we had a little
error handling say if not account it's
an error message so nothing there and if
it worked all we have to do is save it
and maybe say you've logged in yay
so let's say state active account is
account and then we'll do a success
message logged in Thessaly
and then our little prompt will change
straightaway so that should be good
let's try this
over here to the host let's try to log
in and remember there's no real
passwords we're just sort of playing
around with a count here so Michael at
hoc Python dot F M boom logged in
successfully awesome I mean you can see
the prompt changed let's try to log in
again I'll try to just use Jeff @j com
nope could not find email with Jeff @j
com
looks like vlogging is working next
thing we need to do as the host is to be
able to register our cage so then people
can view it and maybe book it that'd be
great right so let's go over here and
work with that now the cage has to be
associated with an owner through this
soft foreign key relationship in MongoDB
so we're gonna require an account and
that's gonna look like just an error
message say like something like this
so we'll just say if there's no account
you must login first to register a cage
alright so now we know we have the
account we're gonna use that as part of
it and let's go ahead and figure out how
many square meters this is going to be
so we'll say meters equals something
like this
now you might adjust directly
that into a float but I found as I was
interacting with this application like
I'd accidentally like go to register a
cage and I meant to list them you want
some kind of way to cancel out so let's
just suppose if they don't enter
anything they just hit enter kind of
short-circuits everything so we'll say
if not
so if they don't enter anything we'll
just bail out so otherwise we'll just
say float of meter so converted from a
string to a float we're not doing error
handling in this right you guys should
probably add that but we're gonna just
do this
and we have to ask a bunch of other
questions is it corporate it does it
have toys things like that and let me
just copy that over cuz your no point
and seeing you this typed in it's just
user input stuff right and then we want
to go down and we want to actually
register the Cade again we want to do
this at our data layer not here in our
application code so we'll say SVC
register cage and again that doesn't
exist but it's going to in a second so
we are going to pass the account
well past the active account here we'll
pass the name of the cage will pass
whether or not it allows dangerous just
all of these items mother not has toys
whether it's carpeted and the meters
okay
so we're gonna go and call this function
which obviously doesn't exist yet but I
John will write it for us
thank you firearm so here we can say
this is an owner here's the name and
string and so on there we go and let's
say this is going to return a cage which
we have to import at the top again Thank
You PyCharm so this is very very similar
to the Korea account we're just gonna
create a cage and save it
so we set all the properties
save and that's going to store it in the
database now we want to remember if we
look over at our owners it has cage IDs
to manage the relationship so the order
in which we do this is super important
now we need to be a little bit careful
with this account here we want to make
sure that we're getting the latest
account from the database so we'll do
something like this we'll say count
equals find a come by email this active
account dot email so that makes sure
that we don't have any stale data
I'm gonna go a count dot cage IDs this
is a list so we can append to the cage
dot ID now it's super important the
order here we must call save so that
this is an actual generated value it's
just none beforehand so we want to make
sure that's generated in the database
and then we can return the cage so a
little warning up there it goes away
because we are returning the cage
the other thing that we need to do is
this has changed the account but we
haven't pushed those changes back to the
database
all right so our register cage seems
like it's working let's go over here and
let's do one more thing this active
account needs to have that data adjusted
as well so let's go over here to state
and has a reload account that's not
written yet let's do that so this is
super easy to do all we have to do is go
to the database and pull it back so we
have this active account global variable
and we can come over here and say import
the service and here we go say fine
account by email active account email
all right that's all we got to do to
reload it so this will make sure that
when we do work with our state that
active account it's the fresh one that
just got its data changed down here
let's do one more thing before we carry
on let's go ahead and implement register
cage here and that spell suppress
correctly let's be at the ability to
list our cages so that we can test that
this actually worked as to also do a
success message
registered new cage with ID
make that an F string actually gauge
that ID so we got to store that up here
excellent
we'll see that come out but let's go
ahead and we're going to require an
account again which is the same info up
here
you
and all we got to do is get the cages so
let's write something like this we'll
say cages equals service not find cages
for user
all right got to write that function
there we go
creates an account let's not call it
active account I'll just say account
owner
it returns a cage actually not a cage
what does it return returns a list of
cages so we got to go to the typing
module
you're typing and do a cage okay perfect
so what we're gonna do is we already
have the owner and because of our
refresh account stuff it should be fresh
so we'll have cage IDs and we we should
have this account dot cage IDs
right there we can use so now how do we
query for this particular thing we're
gonna do something we haven't seen yet
so we're gonna come to the cage and
again we're going to go to this objects
I'm going to do the query but instead of
saying remember before we had email
equals and that did the query against
MongoDB for testing equality we have
something different we needs to do we
want to go to the ID of the cage and we
don't want to just say well it's equal
to it's not gonna be equal to the list
right we can't say not cage IDs because
one is like an object ID and one is a
list of object IDs so we have to use a
special operator and MongoDB has all
these so-called dollar operators dollar
said dollar in dollar not dollar or
these types of things in the way we work
with those in a [ __ ] engine is we use a
double underscore to say we're applying
this to the ID but then there's this
other thing that we're doing I'm gonna
say in so this query right here may be a
little clean them this query says go to
the cage and find all the cages whose ID
is in this list of ID's right
and now we'll have cages equals this is
a query but we want to execute the query
and sort of snapshot it for our absol
and we'll return cages and that should
make
I have our app totally happy that little
warning in a way okay great so we've
written this function and we've used the
in operator the double underscore to
access it here's our cages we just need
to print them out or see in cages
and let's make these f strings and
welcome here I'll say C dot what do we
want here we want name
let's also print out something like this
you have however many lengths of cages
you have and then we'll print those off
okay let's try to test these two things
that we've written or host we first want
to register a cage actually let's try to
list her cages Logan Michael hat mm-hmm
and the dock pylon thought of him and
let's list our cages you have zero cages
it great
so let's register a cage now we're
logged in at a lettuce
it's 2.2 square meters yes it's carpeted
yes it has toys no has no venomous this
will be bullies cage it looks like we
haven't set the price hmm we've
forgotten something haven't we
okay so good thing we tested that here
their price and this will be how much
are you charging alright let's go add
price here price cage that price okay it
was kind of annoying that that crash but
it's also cool why is that cool because
hey we said the cage must have a price
and he didn't if that was regular
MongoDB that would have just let that
happen but because it was [ __ ] engine
not all right let's do this again
bless my cages oops bless my cages we
have no cage
let's register Cade do this again
you
how much of recharging or charging $29 a
night this isn't one fancy cage folks
boom we've registered a new cage now
let's list your cages we have one cages
well maybe a plurality thing there but
boole's cage is that let's register one
more cage there's a huge cage it's
carpeted it has all the toys and this
one's even for venomous snakes this
would be
the large boa cage who knows and this is
3039 now if we look at our cages we have
two cages beautiful so it looks like our
registering and our listing cages is
working great let's add a vocal time to
one of our existing cages we were able
to register cages and list them now
let's make them available for snakes to
stay in so we're gonna work on this
update availability method here we've
got our requirement that you have an
account because they're your cages whose
cages you're gonna manage right things
like that and we're gonna just print out
the list cages I've changed that
slightly so it has a number I'll show
you really quick I'm using enumerate and
an index so it says 1 2 3 instead of
star star star because we want to ask
like hey what cage do you want to work
with so we're gonna add that here and
just for the sake of time I'm just gonna
paste that so it's gonna say what case
do you want because you can cancel or
it's going to parse that into an integer
and then we're gonna work with a
particular cage so let's go down here
and say selected cage Oh first we need
the cages let's say cages equals we'll
just use our service again
get the cages for state that active
account and we'll down here it could
enhance the cages of cage number minus
one because we're showing into them one
two three we got to convert that back
zero-based
okay once we've got our cage set we need
to get the dates we've selected this
cage will say the name that you're gonna
work with and then we're gonna say enter
a date year-month-day that you'd like to
start this available time slot on and
for how many days right so I want to
start a particular date and make that
available for five days now we're using
this thing called parser and that comes
from date util so Python - date utils
module name it's in the requirements
already harsher is a really sweet way to
parse date times it has many many
different formats that understand so
we're going to use that instead of the
built in date time parsing now once we
have this we just need to go and use our
service and write another data access
method so we'll say add available date
and what are we gonna pass we have to
have a count let's say active account
there with the selected cage that we're
gonna add it to we have to have the
start date and the days and let's go
ahead and say state dot reload account
because this might change the account
and then we want to have a little
success message like hey good job
and F string this
okay so now we're down to just pure data
access and [ __ ] the interesting part
right let's go
have pycharm add that function I'm up a
few things here so this is going to be
an owner
date time
you
in an INT and that's go return
nothing ok this looks great - remember
what we're adding here is actually a
booking and bookings are not top level
items but we'll go and create one to get
started and I'll say booking and is a
booking like so and once you've got to
set the properties this when we got to
do a tiny bit of math here so we'll say
start date plus time Delta
you
now we want to change the cage the way
it's working probably it's fine to just
change the cage and call save but I want
to make sure that we absolutely are
working with what's in the database so
I'll say cage equals
actually we can just look it up here I
think I'm not sure if we need it again
so we'll just say Cage dot objects ID
equals Cajun ID dot first okay then
we're gonna go over here I selected kids
I was that's just that here okay
bookings are not top-level items they
live inside of the cages so here we're
going to append at the booking here and
we call save on the cage not on the
booking object right because it doesn't
live its own lives inside the cages
returned a cage I suppose if we want you
know cuz here's kind of the updated cage
we could even tell consumers that that
happens I guess we don't need our active
account here do we so we can go ahead
and drop that and let's just do a quick
cleanup here get rid of this not doing
that nothing changes there okay great
it looks like we can probably add some
time let's go and try to test this out
here gonna be a host we need to login
let's see our cages okay so we've got
these two let's update the cage
availability the large boa constrictor
one is available so that's gonna be
number two great we've selected it is
gonna be 2018 /a 101 brand new year cage
is available and let's say that's for
five days great a date was added let's
add one more cool now if we list our
cages you can see our low large boa
constrictor cage now has two available
bookings it has this time for five days
and that time for 10 days and neither of
them are booked because no guests have
come along it actually booked it but
it's available and now they can go and
ask hey what cages are available for my
snake and I asked this boa cage this
large Bocage should come up maybe we'll
make a little side money why our boa
constrictor is not using it
so before we finished the host side
where you actually can see your bookings
and things like that that turns out to
be one of the most complex types of
queries we're doing in this entire
application I want to make sure that you
can book some stuff so you can see it so
the data comes out when we write it
that'll make a lot more sense so let's
take a moment and focus on the guests
side of the things let people come in
log in create an account I'll register
their snakes and so on so if we go up to
the top to our little switch action
thing here notice that I'm using the
create and login from hosts there's no
reason to write that code twice we'll
just use that one now the thing I want
to focus on for a moment is adding a
snake and viewing your snake now this is
super super similar to what we already
did so let's go ahead and just talk
through this real quick instead of right
from scratches so just like before we
have to have an account whereas a few
basic questions like what is your
snake's name let them cancel by hitting
nothing in the first one get the
information about the snake and then we
call the function add snake and you know
you could see this is very very similar
so we're gonna get the owner get the
owner back and maybe it makes more sense
because we've been writing the others
like this to go like this when I create
the snake and save it but remember the
relationship between snake and owners is
managed by the snake IDs inside of the
owner so we're gonna go get a fresh copy
the owner from the database update that
and save it and then we'll give back the
snake that we just created also we call
a quick reload account to make sure the
snake ID is for some reason if they get
reuse real quick are in the active in
memory account so that's all at me and
secreting snake just like creating the
cage was so everything is exactly the
same there and then to view your snakes
we just write the function get me the
snakes for the user and then we loop
over them that again is very much like
the cages we get the owner in this case
just to be sure that we have the fresh
set of IDs there and then we do the ID
in honor dot snake IDs and we call the
all function and then convert it to a
list
Aiko's we could probably skip this but
either way this is all good
so this gives us our snakes and we're
gonna list it out let's goodness run
that to make sure this is all working
here this time we're gonna be a guest
and let's go ahead and log in and this
time I want to log in as Sarah so Sarah
is gonna be my guest and Michael is
gonna be the person with the cages but
login so we're logged in as Sarah and
let's say I'd like to view my snakes hmm
you have zero snakes okay let's add a
snake they don't have slither and
slither is 1.2 meters long this is a
large gardener and no those are not
venomous so we've created slither and
let's add one more snake this is gonna
be bully and bully is 0.5 0.4 m/s book
it into a cage and viewing it that kind
of stuff is all finished
so we have cages we have available dates
and cages and we have snakes time to
book a snake into a cage and one of
those available dates this turns out to
be one of the more complicated things
we're gonna do in this application and
there's a lot of like input and juggling
stuff so I'm gonna paste a few things
here just about asking questions about
the dates and stuff and then we're gonna
go and write the database queries from
scratch so let's start here we're gonna
start by making sure you have an account
and then we're going to get all the
snakes and make sure you have a snake
because having a counter is not enough
you also have to have a snake you can
put into there we're gonna ask some
questions about Boyan do you want to do
this we're gonna use Python date util to
parse that so just like before we're
gonna do a little air handling to make
sure like you're not trying to book some
sort of reverse thing like I check in
before I check out I check out before I
check in something like this right okay
so then the next thing we need to do is
find out the available cages and this is
where it gets interesting so we're gonna
write a function called get available
cages I'm gonna take the chicken the
chicken and the snake oh we also need to
figure out which snake you want so first
of all let's do a numerate list out your
snakes and we'll say snake one that's
negative is that and you'll pick the
snake okay so take our snakes pick that
got our K our time and they're going to
go to the database and find particular
cage that we can work with now that's
not all there is to it so this is just
going to get us the cages that could be
booked and then we have to ask that's
this little section right here then we
have to let the user pick a cage and
we'll find the underlying booking behind
it so let's write this function so this
is gonna be a daytime daytime and a
snake
you of course don't have to put the type
hints but I find like at the data access
layer it's really helpful maybe through
it you can see you through the rest of
the application I'm not doing this but
at the data access layer I find it
really helpful to say these are the
things that go in these are things that
go out this is like how we're working
with the database okay so here's where
we get down to business I want to come
here let me move this up for you so we
need to do a couple of things we need to
find all the cages that have bookings
that are not booked between this time
and that time all right and we need the
snake information because we not all
cages allow poisonous snakes and they
don't all necessarily fit if I have a
20-foot snake I can't put it into a two
foot cage so let's just do a little
quick rule of thumb to say if your snake
is four times longer or more than the
cage then the snake can't go into it
right snakes can curl up but they can
only curl up so much so we'll say
something like the minimum size of the
cage we're gonna get its snake dot
length over four okay so this this is
gonna be part of our query the dates
gonna be part of the query and the
whether or not it's venomous or not you
want to do a few interesting things here
this is definitely I'm part of the more
complicated query so I'm go to the cage
and we'll say objects and when you have
these complex queries I find it's nice
to spread this across multiple lines so
I'll say dot filter multiple filters and
these are effectively and I'll say
square meters now I'd like to say let's
say equals midsize or greater right just
like we saw with the doubler operators
about in there's one for greater than
equal and we can say the square meters
are greater than or equal to if this
minimum size but that's not the only
thing that we need we also need to go
and do another pretty wild thing we want
to go to the bookings
I remember just refresh over here we
have a cage the cage has a bookings
field we go to the definition for
bookings bookings have a check-in date
and I check out date we want to work
with that how do we do that in [ __ ]
engine
we come over here and we can traverse
that hierarchy with underscores as well
so we can say bookings dot check-in date
and we want to have the check-in date a
four or equal to the check-in that was
passed right so the time you can
check-in has to precede the time this
person is checking in and will do
something similar for checkout
okay so this is part of the query now if
the snake is poisonous we also want to
say that they allow poisonous snakes so
we'll say this will say if snake dot is
venomous we need to augment this query
so we can do that because it hasn't
executed yet it's like the potential to
be executed so we can say query equals
query dot filter and what this thing
allow dangerous snakes that's what we
want to work with
goes true because non dangerous ones can
stay in cages that will either allow or
not allowed dangerous snakes but if it's
venomous we have to have this additional
criteria and maybe we want to have some
kind of order by like we'd like to show
them the cheaper ones so let's go like
this will say cages equals will finalize
the query like this will say query order
by
now you don't do this sort of default
this named parameter type thing for this
you want to order by price default is
ascending so cheapest ones first and
maybe you want to see the biggest ones
first as well so we'll say square meters
like that so we're gonna say first order
my price lowest the highest and then
show us if like the price is the same
show us the largest ones at that price
level down to the smallest ones
excellent so this is pretty much working
it turns out it looks like it's gonna
completely work but it turns out that
there's a challenge you're gonna run
into you and in pymongo this is
straightforward to solve all the we have
to use a lot of operators these dollar
operators to make it work but I haven't
found a good way in [ __ ] engine and so
I still find unbalanced that work in
[ __ ] engine even for this query is
better but here's the problem
what does queries asking you're probably
thinking it looks right yeah you know it
takes a moment to realize the challenge
we're hitting here what this query says
is go to the cage and find me the cage
with the square meters at least minimum
size that's totally fine that works
perfectly and it says show me where
there's a booking greater than checkout
and there's a booking oops this should
be greater than that was almost an error
so where there's a checkout date past
equal to or past where I'm willing to
check out for my snake the problem is if
I have let's say 20 bookings in this
cage right I probably want to check one
more thing but I can just check it down
more book enough to do one more bit at
the bottom but the problem is what if
to bookings one that starts way in the
past but the checkout is like one day
later and then there's another one where
the checkout date is way in the future
but you can only check in waiting day
before and these are not the same
bookings right there's a booking where
the check-in date is before the check-in
and there's a booking where the checkout
date is after the checkout but those are
not the same you need to say there's an
individual booking not like some set of
bookings where one matches one clause
and the other matches the other so the
way you do that in [ __ ] is you say
dollar element match think it's L match
match my element matches the the
description of the thing so you could
say both it must have both of these but
I don't see how to do that in [ __ ]
engine it seems like it should be
possible but it certainly is possible
for equality but for the these operators
plus element match didn't seem to work
for me anyway if you figure out feel
free to use element match I didn't so
I've got to add one more line here and
I'm just gonna copy that over real quick
and I'll talk about it so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say let's go and
actually these are the cages we care
about I'm gonna iterate over the query
which executes sit here and remember the
cage each cage contains the number of
bookings for each booking I want to
check that both the check-in is before
and the check-in is after and
the snake ID is none so it's not already
booked during that time so if it's both
available and the check-in and check-out
date matches then we can make that part
of our final cage there if I don't catch
a list okay so and it says it returns
this but actually what it returns is a
list of cage here we go okay so that's
what we got to do if I could get element
match to work with greater than lesson
in [ __ ] engine this would not be
necessary you could just straight up run
that query but anyway it's not a huge
deal remember this set is already
filtered down to where significantly
right where the check in and check out
the do match it just happens to be maybe
one more thing as missing there okay so
we're getting the available date so
let's come back to our guests here we've
got our available cages now we just have
to like show them to the user and let
them pick it all right so let's just
take some pre-written code for this
there are certain number of cages
available and we're going to enumerate
over them and don't need the average
rating right now
do like this we're gonna print out the
name the square meters whether it's
carpeted and whether or not it has toys
I don't want that to be true false let's
put that yes or no like more friendly
right and if there's no cages sorry
there's no cages but if there are we'll
ask you which one and we'll pick that
out you know zero-based of course and
finally I don't think dizzy was gonna be
booked a cage and then actually we'll
just give out this nice little air mat
this nice little success message saying
hey you booked it for this time so last
thing to do with this book in a cage is
to actually book it so let's go over
here if I turn right at one more time
here and now what we're gonna do is
we're going to loop over that cage is
booking so the way it works is they've
selected a cage they haven't selected
individual booking so we just have to go
one more time over the bookings and go
let's find a booking within this cage
which we know exists because it's in the
list and let's assign it to the snake
so we'll do something like this well
come down here and we'll start out by
and that's a little booking - nothing
just in case for some odd reason we
don't find one want to go through and
again do this similar test as we did
right there right we got to find the
available booking within the cage we
know it exists but we got to fight it
then down here we're going to just set a
few things say the booking daaad guest
and get a little telltale sense
auto-completion if you want
said the guest owner ID I guess we
probably gotta pass the account as well
we'll say
that ID they booking Dodd
set the booked date it was booked right
now regardless of when the booking was
now I also need to set the snake
there we go and the
we gotta go back and save it but
remember don't call save there we call
cage not save okay excellent now I think
it just believes that's a misspelling
but I'm gonna say it's not alright so
that should let us book a cage whew that
was a tough one right so pretty
interesting query we're using the
operators greater than less than we're
traversing the hierarchy and like I said
we're sort of effectively in memory
applying this element match
well that match work the [ __ ] engine
but I couldn't get it to work with both
element match and the operators so
anyway this will be fine come down here
and given a cage we'll pull out the
booking we probably could structure
slightly differently so we could skip
this step and somehow capture the
booking directly but this is fine it
works plenty fast for what we're doing
set the hey you booked it values of the
booking and call save alright I think
it's time for us to test our our book a
hooker cage and I noticed I almost
forgot to add this here state dot active
account when I added it below so let's
go and run this
I'll come in here it will be whoops be a
guest and let's go and login
and let's see our snake so we have these
two snakes neither of them are venomous
let's book a cage wanna start by booking
this now how do I know that date because
over here we have two available bookings
for the large boa cage and these times a
1 to 6 in January so we'll go to let's
say 2 to 4 should be fine at this 4 and
it says which snake remember we it
matters the size of the cage and snake
as well as where there's a venomous so
we'll pick us live there and hey look
the one cage is here let's say alright
let's book it we've successfully booked
the large boa alright now we haven't
written view your bookings but we do
have that I believe might have that for
the other one go over here as a host and
we log in as Michael I think we might
not have implemented this as well but we
can list our cages yes there we go we
can see that we have two cages bully's
cage and large bow and look at that one
somebody has booked this one this slot
for the large bow cage yes it looks like
that worked successfully just like we
expected
we're down to the very last thing we're
gonna do as a guest which is to view our
bookings we were able to book a cage but
as a guest we couldn't see he you know
can't say what are your upcoming stays
for your snakes and things like that so
again just for the sake of time let me
go over here and put some pre-written
code and we'll go write the data access
layer
so require an account
and we're gonna call get bookings for
user and this is gonna return a set of
bookings and just to remind you what
that looks like the bookings are gonna
have the date possible reviews the snake
ID is going to be really important so
what we want to do is we want to say
give us the snake given a snake ID and a
super simple way for us to do that is to
actually just generate a dictionary
using a dictionary comprehension so this
little expression on here it's going to
create a dictionary where the key is the
ID and the value is the snake for all
the snakes belonging to us whoever the
logged in user is then we're gonna get
the bookings and we'll this part we're
gonna write and then we're gonna loop
over here and we're gonna print out a
the snake and we use the dictionary
lookup to get the name here when I print
the cage name and
you know for daytime there
create a date time and do a little bit
of math here on the checkout so we're
gonna turn this back in today so you're
checking in on this day for five days
something like that okay so that's what
our view bookings UI that's pretty much
a stretch right with our app but that's
kind of a this is kind of the UI code if
you will but we got to write this get
bookings for a user this is going to be
Abby's on object ID
bring it back is a list bookie and I
believe now notice one other thing
before we write this code over here
we're saying b dot k dot name now cages
have bookings but bookings don't have
cages there's not a super nice way to
create that reverse association in [ __ ]
engine so what we're gonna do is part of
what we're gonna do in this function is
we're going to set up that relationship
and let's call this user ID or account
ID something like that okay so the first
thing we need to do is find the owner so
call this account equals let's pass in
an email instead something like that and
before I forget passing the email there
okay great so we'll have our account and
we've already verified that they're
logged in so we can just assume that
that happens so we can say books cages
and so we can find all the cages that
have been booked by this person so we
can say cage objects and now we'll do a
few other interesting things we haven't
seen yet safe filter and here we'll say
bookings
double underscore and then we're looking
for what let's see the guest owner ID
let's go to our booking
that matches the owner that equals to
account that ID
we don't actually care about all the
details about the cage and you could
skip this little part right here but
just as it is a means of efficiency we
can come over here and say only we
haven't talked about this yet so what we
can do is say we only want to get back
two pieces of information not
potentially tons of information in this
document we want the bookings and we
want the name so when we say cage name
above that means something right so
let's create the bookings and we'll do
this with a list comprehension so we'll
say bookings is this I'm gonna write in
one way and then we have to make a
change do this reverse association with
the cage so I can say booking
booking in the book cages but remember
there are other bookings that are
unrelated to us here right it could be
two different snakes stay in the same
cage different days we need a little
test
all right so this is gonna be the
bookings of that are assigned to us
within the cages for which we have
booked right so show me all the cages
where we've booked at least one of the
bookings and we're gonna strip out the
unrelated ones so you might think that
what kind of done and it work very very
closely Don but we're not done
so we'd run this you should see this is
gonna crash
isn't that line right there now oh I
almost messed this up so this is
actually for cage into both cages and
each cage contains the booking so we got
to do a double loop here booking in cage
bookings whoo so what we're gonna do is
going to take this hierarchical list of
cages which inside nested inside them
contain a bunch of bookings and we're
going to flatten that list with a double
loop go through each cage go through
each booking and just turn that into a
list and across all those bookings
across all the cages only show the ones
which we some point have booked okay so
this is close but if we try to run it
this reverse lookup of the cage here
it's not going to work so let's see we
can try to run that real quick save
Morgana Sarah
we try to view your bookings the no cage
so let's do a one more little trick we
can do a transformation at this level
right this is like the select part of
the list comprehension now this has to
be an expression and I don't think we
can do this with a lambda expression
because it it doesn't allow us to make
modification so we got to define this
little milk local function so I'll say
map
cage to booking
given a cage in a booking it's gonna be
the silliest thing you've seen book
named cage equals cage well and then
we're going to return cage sorry booking
so why do we need that we need that so
we come down here and we add dysfunction
it's gonna take a booking and it's going
to put that same booking right back into
the list but the booking will be changed
in that it's going to have a cage
associated with it okay so I know that's
not super obvious budget that's what we
need to make that one line work oh I
made a quick error here
those ahead booking cage here in cage
booking there so cage booking gate
bookie okay looks like it's ready let's
try it
you
all right it's fewer bookings whoa it
works we have one booking our snake
slither is booked in the large boa on
this dais for five days so let's add one
more booking just to make sure this is
working so booked a cage
all right so let's try to book that
other available booking this time one
could put bully in there and I guess
when I book that one great if we view
our bookings again you know how our
snakes booked into the different
sections at the different times let's
just try one more time now that those
bookings should have been used up to see
what happens let's try to book one more
cage say we'll start on that date I'll
check out on that date and we'll use
this one sorry
no cages both the available slots have
already been booked just so happens to
be to our snakes awesome
it looks like the guest side of things
is 100% working we just have one
function left to right or viewing the
bookings as a host
what bookings available booking dates
and your cages have been booked and it
will be done with this application so
this require account stuff paste that
that's the same nothing special there
now we want to get the cages for the
current user it won't guess what we've
already written that find cages for user
state active account that's cool so that
was already done at some point along the
way and then what we need to do is we
want to get the bookings and we want
actually a flat list of these are all
the available slots that people have
booked across all the cages alright so
what we're gonna do is thing called
bookings like this a list comprehension
and we're going to use sort of a dual
comprehension to flatten it so I'm gonna
put something here one and two things
I'll stay with those are for in a minute
so we want to say 4c and cages and then
for each cage we're gonna say for B in C
dot bookings and we don't want all of
them right there's already a way to see
that kind of stuff
but what we want is the ones that have
been booked we know they're booked
if booked time or the book date was set
so say if B dot booked date is not none
what do we want to get back here we want
to get the cage in the booking so we're
gonna get a flat list of all the
bookings and along with it we're gonna
carry along it it's booked its cage that
it came from so that's pretty
straightforward and then that's this
part getting them as a flat list and
then the last thing to do is just print
them out and that's a lot of typing for
not a lot of values so let's paste that
over well import date/time and we're
gonna as we loop over them we're gonna
unpack that tuple so the CB here gets
unpacked into the CB right there and
I'll say for this cage oh it's booked on
this date by so it so alright it looks
like this is gonna work I have a lot of
faith in it let's give it a try well
come over here we're gonna be a host
when I login is me
and are you ready one more truth be you
your bookings no there's no duration in
days ah so where did this duration in
days go so this is the booking let's
look at the booking real quick here it
has a check-in and check-out date let's
add this duration in days now if we add
it as an actual thing that [ __ ] Engine
saves that won't be so great because
it's going to have duplicate data
check-in and check-out and days like
they could get out of sync so what we're
going to do is want to add a property so
have a property called duration in days
ah so close days at the same yesteray
ssin in days so down here we just need
to use the time Delta to figure out what
that is
so we'll say DT equals self not check
out date - self not check in date and
we'll return DT da days all right let's
try to run this again double double at
come on too much help here
here we go all right coming as a host
vlog as me Oh ready you your bookings
tada beautiful and you can see our
property is working just right there so
5 days and 10 days now remember when we
actually check we said we're gonna book
it we could book it for a subset of time
we just don't store the data for how
long the user said versus how long the
time slot was so they kind of get that
whole slot and that slot it's worth 5
days and 10 days in duration but given
the data that we're keeping this is
working totally well so I think we've
done everything we can create an account
login we can list our cages we can
register a cage which we already did we
can update the availability which is how
we got these slots we can view our
bookings which we just wrote and we
could even get a little help and go back
to the main menu and we could check out
the guests just one more time around
again create login same thing it says
book a cage that's reserved a cage for
your snake we saw that we can add snakes
oh I got a login as Sara she's the one
with snakes she has
takes there she can view her bookings
from the perspective of her snake not
from the available slots things like
that right she only sees her bookings
not all the bookings across everything
and we go back to the main menu or
because we're done we can say goodbye to
snake B&B
but let's review some of the core
concepts we saw along the way if we want
to insert an object we just create a
standard Python object style we just say
owner equals owner call the initializer
we could either pass the values as
keyword arguments or we could say owner
dot name equals name owner died email
equals email and at this moment there is
no idea associated with this object but
then we just call owner dot save and now
the object ID or whatever the primary
key is we you can set functions to be
called when that happens for that
generation whatever that's gonna be
we've got it's set after you call save
so now you can start working with it
as if it came from the database we also
might want to insert a bunch of things
it turns out if you have a hundred
thousand items to insert and you create
one save create one call save create one
call save it's a lot of database back
and forth and it's very slow so what you
would rather do is create a list of them
so here we have a bunch of snakes we
want to say if we create a bunch of them
put them in this list and then you call
snake that objects not insert and you
give it the list and that's much quicker
if you want to do a bulk insert type
thing we sound like query in the
database is pretty straightforward the
way it works is we start with the
collection the type that represents the
collection we want to work with and then
we say dot filter so here we're saying
filter and we want to do a match where
the email equals the value of the email
variable and you get more than one thing
in here you get a more than one filter
statement and those basically combine as
an and now this would return a
potentially a bunch of owners but we
don't want a bunch of owners we want the
one that we know matches this email so
we can say dot first and it'll give us
the one or at least the first item to
match if there's no no magic we get none
back we don't get a crash or anything
like that when we're quitting against
just plain straight fields in our object
that's pretty straightforward we said
email equals the value that we're
looking for but if we're looking deep
inside of a hierarchy can get a little
more I'd say non-obvious
so we're combining two really
interesting things here we're going to
the cage I'm going to search within the
bookings
embedded document lists my bookings with
a list and it contains a bunch of these
booking objects so the first thing that
we're doing is using double underscore
say bookings guest snake ID so we're
looking at the value guest snake ID of
the booking items within that list and
we're also applying the in operator so
the double underscore in means the
collection on the right we're doing an
in test for the various booking and
snake ID so we use the double underscore
to separate and navigate the levels and
sub documents as well as to apply the
particular dollar operators and then
what I consider a best practice is to
fully execute the query before you leave
this function if we just return to book
cages it kind of still is not yet
executed it hasn't quite talked to the
database and so I want the database to
be done and over with by the time we
leave this method so wrapping it in a
list will execute all that stuff and
pull it back for super large amounts of
data there might be reasons you don't do
this but for most of them I would do
something like this
now sometimes you don't want to quality
in your matches you want some kind of
operator like greater than or less than
or in or things like that so here you
can see we're going to the cage and are
finding all the cages
where the square meters is at least the
minimum size so just like with sub
documents we use the double underscore
and the operator name GTE here to
actually do this query all right there's
a bunch of dollar operators you can find
them in the MongoDB documentation and
you apply all of them in this way now
the other thing that we're looking at
here that we didn't do in our app is
count so if we want to know how many
cages there were we could say do the
query dot count and it'll just do a
count in the database rather than pull
all the objects back where you do a
length of it or something like that the
most straightforward way to make changes
to a document or to a record is to go
get it from the database change the
class and call save so in this example
we're gonna go get the owner out of the
database make sure that's all good right
don't have errors I'm gonna create a
snake we're gonna do work with the snake
and then we want to append
the snake ID on to the owners snake ID
collection so on line 11 we say owner
dodd snake ids not append and we give it
this new ID that was gotten from the
snake on line 9 when we called save and
we saved the owner and that's that all
right so we get the document we make a
change to it in the case of line 11 here
and then we just call save and that
pushes it back this works but that's
transfers the entire document out of the
database over to our ABS here TC
realises it processes it and then
reverses that back to the database that
can be slow but that can also have
concurrency issues if two people run
this exact same method at almost exactly
the same time with the same email
address there's a chance that one save
is gonna overwrite the snake IDs or the
other right both of them read the owner
one makes a change one makes change one
saves the other saves we only have one
snake not two so there are challenges
with this but if you're pretty confident
that that's not an issue you're gonna
run into this is a really nice and easy
way to do it
well MongoDB and [ __ ] engine let us
work with these documents make changes
and push them back in there might be a
better way so if we know that we want to
just change some small part of the
document in a very controlled way we
might want to use some of the atomic
operators so here let's suppose that
there's a number of stays filled which
is an integer in the cage so we just
keep track of how many times people have
stayed at it now there probably are
better ways to get this but let's
suppose that is a number and we want to
increment it so instead of pulling the
cage back and doing a plus equals one
sort of thing and saving it we can
literally go to [ __ ] and say increment
this number the value of number of stays
by one and that could be negative that
could be 10 but I won here so you write
the query dot update one and then pass a
little operator so that's really great
now how about this putting the snake ID
on the owner well we can do that too
so over here we're adding a snake we
generate the snake we call save that's
standard that's an insert but then this
winery of the number of updated we have
owner objects emails email and then
instead of
you know get it back make the change
pinned it to the snake IDs and call save
we're doing something with an operator
so we're seeing update one using the
push operator that's dollar push I'm
going to push it on to the snake IDs
collection another thing we might do
which probably makes even more sense
would be add to set that's another
related operator that will say add this
ID to this set or this list if and only
if it doesn't already exist so you won't
get duplicates right so we're pushing
the snake ID on there that way we'd
never pull the owner back
these are atomic they're perfectly fine
and concurrent situations things like
that so this is time we have to check
that we updated it in a different way
but you know the same effect as we saw
before so [ __ ] engine supports these
in-place updates array operations and
set operations
so like increment as well as push and
these are both better for concurrent
safety think of them as basically
transactional and they're better and
pure performance so they're not always
as simple to work with but they are
better if you can use them there it is
the finish line you have made it
congratulations I hope you've learned a
lot throughout this course we really
have covered a majority of what you need
to program against [ __ ] DB so you've
done it you've crossed the line now you
know enough to start building
applications based on [ __ ] DB so the
big question is what are you gonna build
now I hope you go out and build
something amazing please share it with
me when you do I want to take this
moment to remind you to get the source
code come over to github.com slash mic
see Kennedy slash [ __ ] DB - QuickStart
- course and star and fork this so
you're sure to have a copy so one thing
I do want to take you through really
quick two things one I covered in the
beginning is there is the starter code
which is here this is exactly what we
started from and here is what we have
finished with you can see right there 15
minutes ago I wrote final code but I
also wanted to make sure there were safe
points along the way so if we go back
here and check out the branches you'll
see there's all these different branches
so these are all different save points
that you can grab so if I go here for
example you can see final Richard and
list cages guess
can now book a snake into a cage and
things like so these are different
points in the course that you can go
back and forward to so be sure to make
use of the branches and things like that
if that can help you
you learned a bunch of stuff to program
MongoDB using [ __ ] engine but there's
actually a lot of other things that you
need to take into consideration when
you're doing MongoDB in production for
real applications so I want to encourage
you to check out my paid for [ __ ] DB
for Python developers and just some of
the things we're covering you've seen a
little bit of it but there's actually a
lot more so this is over seven hours of
professional grade MongoDB and Python
programming not just [ __ ] engine but
the core PI [ __ ] the JavaScript API and
so on so let's see a little bit of
what's covered so we talked at in depth
about how to set up your machine whether
it's Windows Mac or Linux the tools that
we're going to use how to get them
installed why the theory behind if no
sequel why no sequel why document
databases MongoDB is native shell and
native query syntax assuming we run
these operations these queries filter
statements and so on in [ __ ] engine how
does that map down to the database this
is important because when you were
running MongoDB and production you need
to be able to use the tools and the
query language to talk to it manage it
right and that is in this native query
API how to model data with documents we
did talk about this we go into more
depth in this course MongoDB from PI
[ __ ] this is the foundation of [ __ ]
engine and basically the Pythons
equivalent of the native query syntax
[ __ ] engine that's we covered a lot of
that in this course so this is pretty
similar high-performance techniques so
performance around document design
performance around indexes and using
profiling to discover where you need
those so that's covered in this course
and super super important is how to
properly deploy MongoDB in production on
the Internet
so it doesn't get hacked and you don't
lose data or anything like that so if
you want to check out this course here's
a tremendously long URL that you very
likely don't want to type so type this
bit dot Lee slash [ __ ] course and
that'll take you right there you can
check it out I encourage you to take
this course if you liked what you saw in
this course here's seven more hours
going even more in-depth so with that I
want to say thank you
thank you so much for taking my course I
really hope you learned a lot and you
enjoyed it please connect with me on
Twitter at M Kennedy or various other
places you find me on the Internet
thanks and see you later